Okay--let's take a step back for a second and talk about
the major pieces of the web--
or the major concepts we're going to be discussing in this lesson.
The major pieces are you, your computer running a web browser,
the internet, and servers.
Your browser makes requests via the internet to servers.
These requests are using a protocol called HTTP,
and the servers respond with files that your browser displays.
Some examples of browsers are Internet Explorer,
Chrome, Firefox.
You're probably running one of those right now.
The servers are computers just like yours,
except they are optimized for sitting in a closet and hosting files,
rather than sitting on your desk--you know--
browsing these files.
And the protocol HTTP that we're speaking
is just a very simple protocol that your browser uses
to communicate with these servers.
We'll discuss each of these pieces--
well, we won't spend a whole lot of time of the internet, but--
we'll discuss each of these pieces in turn throughout this lesson.
Okay, time for another quiz.
What I'd like you to do is take the letters
that are near each piece of technology we just discussed
and match them up with their name and definition.
Your options are: HTTP--the main protocol of the web,
servers--computers that host the files that make up the web,
the internet--the world's largest computer network,
and your browser--a program that runs on your computer
to display files found on the web.
Take the letters next to each piece of technology,
and put them in the correct box.